bonjour à tous bienvenue dans votre 12
13 en direct des jeux équestres mondiaux
au sein du village qui revit ce mardi
pour une deuxième semaine de compétition
nous parlerons voltige des sauts
d'obstacles dans ce journal les épreuves
ont débuté ce matin elles se poursuivent
en ce moment même on attend d'un instant
à l'autre le passage en saut d'obstacles
de là bas normande pénélope leprévost
sur flora de mariposa
mais d'abord place à l'actualité du jour
avec la visite ce matin du tout nouveau
ministre de l'économie dans la manche
pour ta première sortie sur le terrain
emmanuel macron a choisi le sud manche
et la société comme champion européen
des câbles numérique
ce matin il a visité les ateliers avant
de rencontrer les salariés ce midi tran
baigner bonjour vous êtes un arôme ni en
direct vous suivez depuis ce matin la
visite de ce nom du ministre de
l'économie oui effectivement erwan
emmanuel macron est arrivé à 10h45 sur
le site de cette entreprise a comme une
demi heure auparavant il avait rencontré
des élus normands à la mairie de romane
une petite commune de 1700 habitants la
moitié de la population de roumanie qui
a comme emmanuel macron est accompagné
par carole delga la secrétaire d'état
chargé du commerce et axel le maire la
secrétaire d'état en charge du numérique
c'est sa première sortie officielle
emmanuel macron est venu se frotter au
terrain
il est en ce moment avec les dirigeants
de chat comme et des élus dans les
ateliers de cette entreprise qui reste
des fleurons de l'économie régionale a
comme ses 1200 salariés dans la
fabrication de câbles et de fibres
optiques dans des secteurs comme
l'industrie automobile et les télécoms
c'est aussi une coopérative qui a été
créé il y à 81 ans et dont les
actionnaires principaux et bien sont
toujours aujourd'hui des salariés alors
pourquoi avoir choisi a comme et la
normandie vous propose d'écouter sa
réponse voulait aller sur le terrain au
concret il y avait ici
magnifique entreprise une scop je
reviendrai tout à l'heure tu est
formidablement accueillie très heureux
d'être d'être ici voilà alors comme
c'est un exemple justement d'où ce qui
pourrait faire en france oui je le
réussis et qu'on peut pas faire des scop
partout mais là comme c'est un bed très
bel exemple de ce qu'est l'entreprise
on parle de l'entreprise tous les jours
c'est un collectif humain et qu'on
vienne m'expliquer est que je veux aller
voir c'est que tous les salariés sont
impliqués travaillent savent pourquoi
ils travaillent ils sont dedans
elle innove elle investit elle exporte
des formidables alors de leur côté les
salariés de l'entreprise
akon sont habitués à ce genre de visites
ministérielles jusqu'en 2010 il avait
reçu françois fillon qui était alors
premier ministre ait pu en 2013 bien
c'est benoît hamon ministre de
l'économie solidaire qui s'était rendu
sur place
on sait qu'il ya un chassé-croisé
gouvernement entre benoît hamon et
emmanuel macron la semaine dernière pour
l'instant la première apparition
publique du nouveau ministre se poursuit
tout le monde va se retrouver à la
cantine avec mes salariés dans quelques
instants
merci franck reportage complet dans le
19/20 l'autre à l'actualité de ce mardi
c'est la rentrée scolaire le grand jour
du retour sur le chemin de l'école pour
en basse-normandie 140 1597 écoliers 72
1053 collégiens et précisément 123 mille
neuf cents lycéens toutes sections
confondues
une rentrée qui avait un goût très
particulier pour les élèves de l'école
albert camus à à caen il y a près d'un
an et demi l'établissement a été victime
d'un important incendie après la
restauration de l'établissement
parents et enfants retrouvait l
établissement ce matin sur place sabine
daniel et loïc blache par cette partie
là le feu directement parce que le fait
et de côté
mais elle a été refaite parce que
manière venez tout les fumées et toutes
les poussières du feu qui était venu
jusqu'ici tout noirci par tous visite
des locaux avec un directeur heureux ce
matin la rentrée à albert camus un petit
goût de retour les élèves de l'école
vont retrouver leurs salles de classe
dans leur quartier après un an d'absence
pour cause d' incendies lel qui abrité
les classes primaires avait été la plus
touchée
sa durée sur une année quoi le temps
dans des constructions puisqu'il nous on
a déménagé sur l'école l'ancienne école
des cormorans donc on est dans une année
scolaire là bas et les travaux sont
terminés la cet été et sont d'assurance
je dois refaire à l'identique mais on
est très content de retrouver des locaux
qui sont aussi et spacieux si agréable
qu'on connaissait donc là vraiment c'est
un retour un retour aux sources en
gagnent en innovant et scolaires en
chasse une autre nouvelle maîtresse
nouvelle classe nouveau programme
beaucoup de choses restent à découvrir
le maire de caen a fait une tournée
d'inspection pour constater que tout
était rentré dans l'ordre
quant aux rythmes scolaires joël bruneau
se déclare légaliste
nous avons souhaité effectivement avec
amandine françois qui m'accompagne ce
matin donc maire-adjoint en charge de
l'éducation prendre le temps de la
concertation avec les enseignants les
parents les associations pour
effectivement là où c'est nécessaire
revoir un certain nombre des dispositifs
au cours de l'année enfin y réfléchir
pendant l'année scolaire 2014 2015 pour
que ce soit opérationnel pour la
prochaine rentrée
si certains sont contents de retrouver
leur école de quartier pour les cp la
joie de la rentrée est toutefois mitigé
toujours en direct du parc expo dont
nous à présent notre page consacrée à
ces jeux équestres mondiaux florent
turpin
bonjour reprise des compétitions ce
mardi avec le début du concours de saut
d'obstacles et c'est l'épreuve reine de
la compétition ça se déroule en ce
moment même regarder au stade d'ornano
153 cavaliers engagés dans cette épreuve
de vitesse qui compte à la fois pour le
classement par équipe et pour le
classement individuel un parcours contre
la montre vous voyez ici à l'image le
français simon delestre pour l'instant
quatrième du classement provisoire en
attendant surtout nos trois bas normands
kevin staut patrice delaveau et surtout
surtout pénélope leprévost qui devrait
s'engager dans les minutes dans les
secondes qui viennent une autre
discipline a débuté ce matin il s'agit
de la voltige vrai et ça ça se passe au
zénith de caen
regardez contrairement aux apparences ce
n'est pas du cirque ce n'est pas non
plus de la gymnastique
c'est de la voltige et ça commence par
le programme imposé par équipes
des équipes mixtes et il faut de
préciser vous voyez sur cette image des
français leurs habits de lumière les uns
après les autres ces cavaliers gymnastes
en shed enchaînent les figures sur leurs
chevaux c'est très joli c'est très
spectaculaire les français qui rêvent de
décrocher une médaille d'or à l'image de
nicolas andréani numéro un mondial
écoutez le c'était hier à l'entraînement
ça va parfaitement
la bonne nouvelle c'est que mes deux
chevaux ont passé la visite
d'ailleurs tous les chevaux du clan
français ont passé la visite
c'est excitant de se dire qu'on va faire
son premier zénith un petit peu comme
bruel a pu le faire ou ou d'autres voilà
je pourrais dire je les fais mon premier
zénith et pour comprendre à la
discipline on s'arrête ce midi sur cette
discipline une discipline qui tient
autant de la gymnastique que de
l'équitation présentation avec emilie
flahaut et guillaume look il y a deux
mille ans les romains se délecter devant
ses acrobaties la voltige est présenté
comme un jeu en réalité elle faisait
partie des exercices militaires
destinées à améliorer l'équilibré cheval
les futurs pérenne
vinci peu plus tard seuls les tenues ont
changé les voltigeurs ne sont plus
démunis terme et pour arriver à ce
niveau d'excellence ils pratiquent
inlassablement l'équitation la
gymnastique et la danse car la voltige
ces trois sports en un
regarde ça vaut le coup bien demain
février dernier à bordeaux nous avions
rencontré le meilleur voltigeur au monde
le français nicolas andréani
inconvénients avec ses grands chevaux
pour la remettre des coupes je tire mon
petit m il va remettre son titre en jeu
mais il est serein il a confiance en
caisse de nice qui n'est pourtant plus
son cheval habituel faut des chevaux zen
des chevaux qui va pas très sûr l'oeil
qui sont pas trop réactif par rapport à
ce qui peut se passer sur sur
l'extérieur et même et des chevaux avec
une bonne qualité de galop et surtout
beaucoup d'équilibré car la performance
du cheval entre pour un quart dans la
note finale
le reste revient aux voltigeurs qui est
noté sur la technique et sur
l'artistique et c'est souvent là que les
français font la différence
voici jacques ferrari quand il n'est pas
en compétition il se produit en
spectacle avec nicolas en raid
votre amour voltigeurs au niveau
physique il faut être l'éthique petit
peu comme un gymnaste c'est-à-dire très
explosif à ses preuves au niveau du haut
du corps et très green m voilà il n'y a
pas besoin d'être vraiment endurance est
pas un sport d'endurance vous avec
passage à faire d'une minute claque à
chaque passage dure une minute et s'est
vu ce qu'il faut être très pointue très
techniques sur chaque passage et l'autre
qualité première je pense pour être un
bon voltigeurs comme jacques ferrari
comme moi c'est toujours des voltigeurs
qui se dirige un peu vers la danse vers
l'interprétation
lorsque vous êtes trop chimique
technique sur un cheval c'est vrai qu'
il n'y a pas d'âme à votre votre
interprétation
et pour cette finale de coupe du monde
nicolas andréani s'est mis dans la peau
d'albert einstein
au centre de la piste s'allonge ce qui
l'a vu débuter à l'âge de 6 ans 23 ans
qu'ils travaillent ensemble et qu'ils
rapportent des médailles
et pour cette finale de coupe du monde
le couple va en décrocher une de plus
la seule qui leur manque c'est celle des
jeux équestres mondiaux d'autres
français pourraient également brillé en
individuel femmes mais également par
équipes
il n'ya compass 2 2 que la france
n'engagera pas d'accueil voilà superbe
discipline en 1 bernard bonjour vous
êtes le chorégraphe de l'équipe de
france
on compare souvent la voltige au
patinage artistique c'est une connerie
une comparaison qui vous correspond qui
vous convient oui en fait on a des
processus de création des recherches
gestuelle des préparation en amont
notamment sur des barres un peu
technique de danse travail de ligne de
jambes et ensuite après effectivement
l'élaboration du du programme des
programmes parce qu'en l'occurrence il y
en a au moins deux ans voltige programme
technique et programme libre où là on
est en recherche constamment ce qui fait
la force de l'équipe de france et que
très vite depuis très longtemps
maintenant la chorégraphie a intégré le
parcours de ces voltigeurs
alors il ya une vraie vraie école
française de voltige et notamment depuis
vingt ans au moins on travaille
conjointement avec les préparateurs arty
enfin physique et l'entraîneur national
pour que justement on puisse glaner des
médailles grâce à cet aspect artiste ça
apporte beaucoup justement cet aspect
chorégraphique à la note finale est bien
de plus en plus effectivement ils ont un
tel niveau d expertise en terme et
gymnique au niveau du plateau
international que voilà la cerise sur le
gâteau c'est l'artistique qui fait faire
la différence aux français et commencent
à se créer une chorégraphie de voltige
ans alors on rentre processus
chorégraphique en début au début on est
au sol on se fait en improvisation on
essaye de voir là où on veut aller puis
ensuite apprend pas sur un tonneau ça
c'est un cheval en bois ont ni crème un
petit peu et puis progressivement passe
à cheval au pas et au galop et on voit
qu'il reste et en général il reste
effectivement l'essentiel vient du
cavalier est ce que le cheval ne fait
que de la figuration hostiles à son rôle
également le cavalier et le cheval
le cheval et le cheval il est primordial
parce que sans un cheval de performant
le voltigeur peut pas peut pas donner
son maximum donc il faut qu'il ait une
allure régulière
qui porte et qu'il aide c'est un trio le
longeur le cheval et le voltigeur c'est
vraiment un triller un trio de grandes
ambitions pour l'équipe de france sur
ces disciplines danse et josé castro
mondiaux bah écoute et on va essayer en
tout état de cause les athlètes français
vont très très bien il ya une bonne
phase de préparation à le haineux à
l'école nationale d'équitation à saumur
et donc normalement tout devrait bien se
passer
on suivra tout ça merci à vous romain
bernard debré voltige sur ce plateau de
12-13 repartir à présent dans les allées
du village des jeux où nous attend
florine mba
bonjour florine ce midi vous nous faites
la preuve comme les non voyants peuvent
monter à cheval
absolument et je peux vous dire que
j'observe c'est deux cavaliers depuis
quelques minutes et je vous mets au défi
de trouver lequel des deux est non
voyant voilà ce propos j'ai à mes côtés
christian paul levé bonjour christian
équitation sensitive sens la vue alors
comment fait-on pour monter quand on est
non voyant la grande et non voyants on
n'a pas la vue comme son nom l'indiqué
donc on utilise tous les autres sens et
on prend en exploite toutes les
sensations qu'on peut prendre
il nous en reste deux dans le corps du
cheval son mouvement
et puis nous c'est une équitation que
nous centre beaucoup sur nous mêmes et
sur la relation qu'on a avec le cheval
qui souffre parce qu'on est dans une
bulle avec notre cheval c'est un des
plaisirs de cette équitation là le
cavalier qui est derrière nous juste là
et non voyant comment il ce guide
comment comment ça se passe alors le
principe de cette équitation ce qui nous
a permis de l'ouvrir de plus en plus
c'est qu'on utilise les yeux du cheval
cette notion qu'on a appelé le cheval
kid c'est à dire que le cheval a tous
les atouts en lui pour qu'on lui fasse
confiance pour qu'ils gèrent ces tracés
par rapport à l'espace dans lesquels on
le met et on peut vous le verrez ceux
qui viendront sur la démonstration on
peut le mettre dans des espaces très
complexe et en montant sur des sardanes
technique
le cheval organise ces tracés au milieu
de tous ces obstacles la merci beaucoup
christian on pourra voir des
démonstrations dès à présent juste après
notre direct cet après midi à 15 heures
et demain à 16h30
merci à vous florine l'on revient à
présent sur la discipline de saut
d'obstacles une discipline dans laquelle
les propriétaires de chevaux sont en
fait les véritables sponsors des
cavaliers parmi eux je ne
maigret propriétaire de la jument de
pénélope leprévost sur ces jeux
équestres un partenariat gagnant gagnant
pour les deux femmes reportage catherine
berra patrick merde chez les maigret le
cheval est depuis toujours une affaire
de famille
une passion commune alors lorsque je ne
viens va lâcher la médecine qu'elle
exerçait depuis 25 ans en région
parisienne pour se lancer dans l'élevage
c'est tout naturellement marier sa fille
l'ont suivi mon mari m'a toujours
énormément soutenu et sur ce point
financièrement parce que c'était quand
même aussi important j'ai dit adieu à la
médecine j'ai vendu ma clientèle pour me
consacrer exclusivement aux chevaux
c'est vrai que ma passion c'est les
chevaux de jambi donc même si
vraisemblablement élever des chevaux pur
sang serait peut-être plus lucratifs
quelque part
j'ai besoin moi de du contact avec
avec mes chevaux de les monter
éventuellement de
de les avoir un certain temps autour de
moi est bon ça ça n'existe pas tellement
en aidant les chevaux de course les
maigret ont fait l'acquisition du et red
bull avec 188
ils viennent de s'agrandir avec la
poterie située à tourgéville c'est là
que l'activité de l'élevage a été
transféré la poupée larmes à pierre
poulin jeunes chevaux ils grandissent
tranquillement jusqu'à leurs quatre ans
avec un ouvrage à deux ans en attendant
de devenir un jour ou pas des bêtes de
concours le bon cheval
c'est le cheval qui fait bien ce qu'il
sait faire après bon ben si on a la
chance de sceller des gagnants des
gagnants groupe ou si nous on a de la
chance d'élever des chevaux de haut
niveau c'est formidable mais déjà ce qui
est important c'est qu'à cheval fasse
bien à son niveau
12 polinière cinq étalons neufs chevaux
de gran pulsé le fonctionnaire de
geneviève mégret qui couvre ainsi toute
la filière du cheval de sport de
l'élevage à la compétition de très haut
niveau on passant par la formation des
jeunes chevaux le commerce et
l'étalonnage au départ il n'était pas
forcément question d'aller si haut dans
la performance mais nahyane a monté
depuis quatre ans par pénélope leprévost
a entraîné tout le monde dans son
sillage
et c'est vrai que le haut niveau c'est
grisant alors y'a pas que des bons côtés
toujours mais c'est vrai que c'est assez
c'est assez
à ce niveau là ce qui est sympathique
c'est le partager
c'est le partage des joies des peines
aussi parfois mais c'est
voilà chacun donnait quelque chose alors
pour obtenir un résultat n'est pas
aujourd'hui que propriétaire mais c'est
vrai que c'est un métier et qu'il faut
avoir les reins solides car quand on est
propriétaire de chevaux de sport il faut
s'attendre à dépenser beaucoup d'argent
sans forcément en gagner un risque
financier et humain nécessaire cependant
car en france on n'a pas encore trouvé
d'autres moyens pour soutenir
l'équitation de haut niveau en direct à
l'épreuve de saut d'obstacles des jeux
équestres mondiaux corinne bien rota
bonjour vous êtes au stade d'ornano
y'a pas normal qu'un peu près 2 entre en
piste oui elle vient d'entrer en piste
pénélope vous voyez elle va s'élancer
dans quelques secondes vous entendez
l'ambiance la foule acclame
on compte beaucoup sur elle le premier
français simon delestre n'a pas fait de
faute il n'est pas dans les premiers
mais il n'a pas fait de fautes donc
c'est déjà un bon point pour l'équipe de
france et on attend de pénélope avec
cette très très jeune jument flow
raz-de-marée pause acquis 1 seulement 9
ans pénélope là depuis un an seulement
et on attend d'elle qu'elle rentre bien
dans la compétition et on voit madame
maigret justement un image à l'instant
la propriétaire du cheval de pénélope
leprévost voilà pénélope est partie elle
avait le numéro 1 c'est parti pour ce
premier obstacle voilà et ça commence
bien
donc elle a bien franchi le numéro 1 je
pense qu'elle ne va pas prendre trop de
risques bien franchi ce gros auxerre
jusqu'à présent tout se passe bien la
jument habite à l'air de bien écouter et
jusqu'à cet obstacle numéro 5 qui a posé
beaucoup de problèmes aux cavaliers du
début de la matinée et s'est
parfaitement négocié ce qu'il y a
bah oui je crois que ça se gâte la
petite heure pour que dès lors la est là
j'aborde tout de cartes ico très très
délicat
elle met des gens va comme on dit dans
le jargon si je dis hein
la jument était bien au-dessus mais je
crois qu'il ya une petite faute
d'enfants la carrière pas sûr pour la
faute pour l'instant rien est affiché
sur le chrono de la feuillie à 9 e
de toute façon ce qui compte c'est de
réaliser ce parcours le plus vite
possible
quand vous faites tomber une barre à
terre c'est quatre points et c'est aussi
quatre secondes de pénalité sur
l'épreuve de chasse alors on n'aura pas
forcément le temps de finir le parcours
de pénélope leprévost nous reste six
secondes oui voilà il n'y a plus qu'un
job 77 82
c'est la deuxième place c'est magnifique
c'est dire avoue corinne et on a pu voir
c'était super ce parcours de pin up
après vos questions en suspens pour vous
retrouve cet après midi à 15 heures pour
les retransmissions de france tv sport
on n'a pas le temps de vous en dire plus
et encore merci à tous d'avoir suivi
cette édition on est content d'avoir que
vous pu vous faire suivre le parcours de
l'homme aux deux autres cavaliers
bas-normands poursuivons ce concours cet
après midi très bonne journée à tous et
à demain
oui
il
mutualia complémentaire santé et
prévoyance vous présente la météo
bonjour voici de bonnes nouvelles pour
notre ciel normand cet après midi il va
peu à peu partout devenir très lumineux
bleu et très ensoleillé avec juste de ci
de là de petits cumulus inoffensifs vent
faible ou modérée et quelques brises de
mer sur le littoral est de 20 à 23
degrés 20 ha qui recueillait les dieppe
21 au havre 22 à saint-lô caen et rouen
et 23 d'avranches à evreux en passant
par vimoutiers ou alençon demain matin
après dissipation des brumes ou
brouillards
le soleil s'imposera très largement et
il brillera dans un ciel clair à peu
nuageux qui vent faible de 12 à 16
degrés demain après midi le vent sera
faible à modéré le ciel restera très
lumineux est dominé par un soleil
généreux petite hausse du mercure qui
atteindra 25 degrés d'evreux à
vimoutiers le maximum un minimum 21
degrés à dieppe et cherbourg aujourd'hui
mardi 2 septembre bonne fête aux ingrid
et bonne journée à toutes et à tous